in shanghai 26 million people are going
to be locked down but this is china's
zero coveted strategy as it calls it and
it has worked really well so far they've
only registered around 4 600 official
deaths but omicron has arrived here
we've seen waves outbreaks all across
the country now some cities have locked
down entirely some provinces have locked
down entirely sealed themselves off from
china shanghai's been trying to do
something different it's tried targeted
lockdowns telling individuals to stay at
home and what it's trying to do now is
not have a full-on lockdown to restrict
the spread just to lock down uh so that
they can get 26 million people tested um
over the course of eight days they've
said that lockdown will come to an end
there uh so this is sort of precision
testing but at mass scale if you will
but the question is becoming can china
keep the zero covered up if they find
lots of cases in shanghai will they have
to lock down it's the only tool they
have left and will china ever learn to
live with kobe there's no indication
from the authorities yet they're willing
to change their approach especially with
their elderly population relatively
unvaccinated this is about buying time
beating off uh this wave to build those
defenses so that china finally can
perhaps someday down the line learn to
live with covid